so I go all the way back to Charlotte I
pack up my apartment I drive all the way
to Houston with my entire apartment
packed up by the way in a U-Haul like
the next day the next morning we I she's
got people there packing it up movers
mhm we pack it up I drive the U-Haul all
the way to Houston takes a couple
days I unload it into we have uh some
guys unloaded into a uh into a storage
unit cuz I'm going to stay with Becky
until I find my own apartment as we're
driving around the neighborhood super
nice she's living in like whatever like
that like that 20th floor or something
of some huge highrise great
apartment we drive by and I go oh stop
the car and I I I I want to get out
there one of those cone things where
there's flyers for the house for a house
I jump out and I get the flyer and and
she's like what are you doing I well I
just want to you know I look looking at
flyer and she says uh I don't want to do
a scam here I want to live here this
place is nice I love it here and I went
right I understand I said I'm not going
to I said no but I have to find an
apartment MH and she go oh you just I'm
just so disgusting you can't SP stand to
spend even a couple weeks with me you
just and she goes just ballistic she's
screaming at the top of her lungs and I
know she's going to get me caught mhm
she's never going to get me out right
she's already told me that mhm so we go
back to the apartment we go
upstairs I was so scared of this this
chick bro I I was so scared I remember I
was going up in the
elevator and this girl gets on this
clearly a stripper mhm I mean Dro dead
just but wearing stripper clothes yep
and I'm star like and and as soon as she
got on Becky gave me that with the face
and I'm like this I'm like staring in
the
corner and never look at the girl girl
and I remember we get off the elevator
Bing it opens I bolt off it Becky bolt
bolts office and I off the elevator and
I remember she squeals um I bet you just
love the [__] that [__] and the girl as
the elevator doors are closing she goes
hey I thought that was funny so I go to
the apartment yeah we we have a
screaming match kind of tell her I want
to split up the money she tells she's
not going to give me split the money why
um because she said you can go somewhere
else and do this again you'll have a
million dollars right in six months you
know I have to live off this money did
she threaten you oh she threatened the
it was it was funny too because the
conversation back and forth I remember
saying no I want happen and she goes and
she said uh I'll give you $10,000 I said
you're out of your mind I said I said
I'm tell right now you come up with
something reasonable I'll take all of it
mhm and she said um what did she say I
said I'll take all of it she goes and
what Escape in that U-Haul they're going
to she the cops are going to be looking
for in five minutes and I went I just
remember thinking oh wow and keep in
mind all of my IDs everything are in the
storage unit that she has a key to like
I'm not getting those it's over yeah I
got an ID right now that says my name is
Michael eert yeah I driving a I I got
I'm driving a U-Haul Van yeah sounds
like she has a lot of negotiation
leverage right so we start arguing back
and forth and she said
$100,000 I'll give you $100,000 I said
I'll take it she counts it out uh counts
out the 100,000 later when I recount it
it wasn't even 100 it was like 98,000
that's fine it's fine so um but you know
we've got them all marked you know 2,000
5,000 6,000 she's like 2,000 5,000 12
that's she ends up um stiffing me that's
fine it's not my money so I I take it I
end up you know I take it I leave and as
I'm leaving she'd always called me
before on the phone and begged and
pleaded and cried I messed up please
give me a chance I'm sorry I'm I I'll
take my medication I'm sorry I thought
it was better I thought it was okay and
I remember walking out I put my cell
phone on the counter and just walked out
went downstairs got in the truck and
drove